foreign
[Music]
in the important ways you know
in every other Universe Gwen Stacy
evolves for Spider-Man
[Music]
and in every other universe
it doesn't end well
it's the first time for everything right
[Music]
all right
my name is Miles Morales I'm Brooklyn's
one and only Spiderman and things are
going great oh yeah you're supposed to
be here combined all right whatever
whatever
so are you like a cow or a Dalmatian I
am
spot
that's not funny
don't don't do that
miles's grades are pretty good A and AP
Physics that's my little man and a B in
Spanish what okay miles
to you and I think you know it
[Music]
miles
wanna get out of here oh win so wait a
minute there's an elite crew with all
the best spider people in it who's the
new guy danger this is unbelievable this
is the lobby
the whole thing with his idea what's the
guy I gotta do to join this spider team
you can you can never be part of this
don't even get me started on Doctor
Strange and a little nerd back on Earth
1999.99 come on go easy on the kid he
had a terrible teacher Peter files
Heyday you have a baby
I'll take it from here
miles being Spider-Man is a sacrifice
you have a choice between saving one
person
and saving every world
to send me home I can't do that I can do
both Spider-Man always always what about
Uncle Ben if not for Uncle Ben most of
us wouldn't be here
you can't run forever dude I can't lose
one more friend
no idea what are you doing
everyone he's telling me how my story is
supposed to go
I'm gonna do my own thing
stop Spiderman
[Music]
and then I looked at my uncle and let me
guess he died
[Music]
thank you